actually from ETH Zurich and he is a he
was spent some time as a postdoc at
Berkeley spent some time at Oxford in
England as now a faculty member at eth
zurich in the status 64 I want to talk a
bit about the Midwife examples oh yeah
we stuck with me
okay is it better
sino which symptoms States hand in the
past and you know for example of which
drugs they have taken in the past and in
total the database contains about 15,000
symptoms Kota for and 50,000 drugs and
so now when it means pass regression I
mean sparsity in the sense that for
example each patient just has a few
active entries in there which is luckily
the case I mean there's no patient in
there who's had thousands of symptoms
and has taking tens of thousands of
drugs is only maybe ten active entries
or actually it was surprised that most
patients said had hundreds of active
entries but still it's far short of the
total number of 30,000 you have in there
so when I talk about sparsity in this
talk it's really bad sparsity of the
data matrix X itself not about a optimal
regression vector code of that doesn't
necessarily have to be spicier and it
raises kind of two questions I think in
general kind of is there a way to
compact definer since the sparse data
matrix X and get away were with a
regression problem or a classification
problem on a much smaller dimension and
the second question question I think it
raises in generals what do you do barn
interactions because for example for
this data said it has been used a lot
for a drunk surveillance so for example
you want to know well maybe drag a is
good to avoid a heart attack drug bees
also good if you take it but maybe
patients who take drug a and be together
they really get a problem you wouldn't
find out about this in a randomized
controlled experiments so a dative is
like that it is a great chance to find
out about it the problem is only if you
want to encode all possible interactions
for example drug drug interactions like
symptom interactions in this case kind
of you would have to encode a bond if I
found
rich million of them and a for triplets
it's already five trillion so we don't
want to do that necessarily and the
question is is there way kind to
compactified kind of the matrix and some
kind of interaction modeling for spots
spots data matrices of this time they're
two more kind of where I'm going to show
a few examples for the text regression
or classification case and it's kind of
similar so the document is encoded by
words and most documents just contain a
small fraction or forwards so again it's
the spa's sparse matrix and a reputation
scoring experiment which are going to
cover a bit later again so for
regression the pictures a bit like that
you have a target response in RN and you
want to model that as a linear model x
times betastan the point is now that X
is the sparse matrix of the star entries
really code for nonzero elements in here
and don't make an assumption that be the
star is it's necessarily spas and then
you've got some noise and talk and
logistic regression would work in
exactly kind of the same way and the
question is now kind of this little
scheme to compactified in the sense that
you can write the sparse P dimensional
data matrix kind of as a dense matrix in
just L dimensions nowhere else lot
smaller than P and of course you could
use for example random projections or
sub sampling of some type and we looked
a bit into this min wise hashing idea
which seems to be particularly
interesting for sparse data matrices and
we wanted to understand a bit kind of
wise is working I mean they're quite
good empirical results on it and we want
to turn us understand mukam but it
alright so I should go back I'm in wise
hashing kind of the idea is really very
simple so would you do is to get a what
you call a sketch may be off the data is
you permute your columns and random say
say once and then in the muted order you
check from left to right kind of where
do I find the first nonzero entry and
then you know that number don and of
which which element can was the first
nonzero one and then you can repeat that
for a new random permutation and do that
l times so with the idea is that
basically you aim for the Jacka index of
2 cents so you can think about this sets
is that 12 that n is the that I is the
set of Acts of entries for observation
isos the set of entries which are non
zero in the I throw of the data matrix
ax and the interesting quantity is kind
of the Jacka image so it's the fraction
between the size of the intersection
between two sets at eyes at j over the
size of the the union and the
interesting thing in a sense is that
that if you take a random permutation of
your data and you compute your min wise
has so you compute exactly kind of which
entry is the first non-zero one in there
then the probability that you get a
coalition for two observations inj is
exactly equal to the Jacka index and
somehow you want to exploit that a bit
kind of to say well say two rows which
are really similar kind of they they
will have really high chance of getting
exactly the same minimize hash Mallory
India so here's an example it's a
smaller smaller de trompeta matrix X and
I've written one permutation down on
3124 and now you check for example for
the first observation kind of you check
well in that order given by PI where's
the first nonzero entry and for the
first observation you don't have to look
far it's already at the first point so
you write down one for the second one
where pi is equal to one you have zero
entry so you have to go to the next
entry which is too and there you find an
active energy so you would write down
two and so on and so on and then you can
do it for another permutation which is
now say 2413 so you do exactly the same
thing again for the first observation
you check in the first place it's
nothing there a second place there's
nothing there a third place you find
something so you write down with three
here and so on and for the next three
observations for example entry is active
so you get a 1 and for the 4th century
the first active and raised in place too
so you write down or two and so you can
do that as many times as you'd like u
del x and the idea would not be to use
the stents data matrix m for regression
in some way instead of your sparse data
matrix ax so again kind of you would
imagine kind of you can imagine the
dimensionality of X maybe a million or
tens of millions and the dimensionality
of em maybe just a thousand something
like that the problem is only if you
look at em these are really factor so
there's no real meaning to it being
three instead of I mean it's there's no
natural ordering there so the question
is what what do you do about that one
strategy would be to say well for each
column I look at kind of what are the
unique values I get and then I code
those as factors and you can do that the
problem is only you don't know how many
unique values you're going to get in the
large database of say where you've got a
million observations so potentially you
could end up with a large number of
columns which would be unwieldy and so
the neat idea of peabody
why's hashing is to say well I take my
data matrix m and then I kind of
randomly map all unique values into just
two classes by just keeping the last bit
of em so which would mean the one would
like to 12 moves 20 Tim's 20 here and
the three maps again to one so for each
column essentially you divide into two
blocks and if you've got the same value
m in here they're gonna end up in the
same block and if they have a different
value then they might still end up kind
of with the same valuing here ok and now
you've got binary data matrix m and you
can use that kind of two to repression
and it's it's not immediately obvious
kind of why that should work so we
wanted to look a bit into that and you
can also extend this to be bid kind of
would be is larger than one so you can
keep more than the last bit and actually
ping li who has more or less invented
than she should be here but I haven't
seen him it's over here can you raise
your hand but and not but I think he
gives the talk tomorrow so he can give
you the Oh done something wrong ok and
the complication is a bit kind of you
want to study exactly this game there
were a lot of dependencies created kind
of x by the fact that the same n values
always Matt comes to the same last bit
and so what we said well we said kind of
let's make Matt's mapping into two
groups kind of more explicit explicit
randomly and what we call mrs map and
the advantage since i found if you don't
have to decide really how many bits to
keep you can get a bearable importance
of measure and also you can deal with
data matrices which have which are not
not binary but have continuous entries
which i think this is helpful sometimes
in practice and it's it's less efficient
to implement so you pay a price for that
so but it's not too bad so the idea
again kind of this is the workflow
innocence of off p bids wind wise
hashing and what we do is exactly the
same but now the mapping kind of from
the unique values of M into the new data
matrix s is explicitly random so for
each of these unique values kind of you
you assign a random sign either minus 1
0 1 and you're going to work with that
so for example here in the first 12 maps
2-1 and right is randomly chosen and one
maps to one in the third column one maps
to minus one and two and three map-21
and then you keep essentially just the
data matrix s and you do linear
regression or classification just just
using that data matrix in the end and
continuous variables can in that game
easily be dealt with so say you've got
instead of just two spine erient is
you've got a four point two entry there
then you would just multiply that entry
with the corresponding sign so oh sorry
I left out a step I think here the H
matrix I have to explain care of that
instead of em which is the meaning of
pie else that I kind of you can also
keep the arc men and it's a bit easier
conceptually because the entries in age
really the actual variables kind of
which were chosen as the which had the
first nonzero entry so so if you look
here for example an H entry of two means
that really the second variable came up
first in the random permutation and an H
value of three and three means that this
one was responsible kind of for the
first nonzero entry in both of these
random permutations but it's it seemed
exactly
the equivalent it's just I may be more
convenient way to think about it and so
you can see for example here the third
variable was chosen kind of foot for the
two random permit races so you can map
this 4.2 you multiplied with the random
sign chosen for the variable three in
these two cases and so you get your data
matrix S which is just the
multiplication of a random sine x your
actual data entry X which now can be
continuous if this is too confusing it
doesn't matter it's the binary case kind
of contains all the important stuff but
I still thought it's important kind of
that you can deal with continuous
variables is at least one and now you
can do this so you create your tents
data matrix S which if X is binary it's
just just contains minus ones and ones
and the question is then well can you
find a regression vector b b star in RL
such that this is really close to the
original problem if p is a lot lighter
than than hell okay and if you can do
that then you're almost there because
then you just need to do come up with
these estimation error on top which is
going to be small because L is really
small so this is kind of the crucial
step and if you think about it you can
ask yourself well say L is equal to one
say a dual only ones can I find a
construction for the beta beast on such
that the expected value of the right
hand side is exactly equal to the left
hand side so that I have an unbiased
estimator if you will of X beta star and
there is a way I kind of to do it so I'm
just going to deal with the binary case
know where X is binary and so s the
matrix s just contains your randomly
chosen signs and so in here you've got
your randomly chosen science where
h 1 star the the variable which was
responsible for the first nonzero entry
for the first observation and so on and
b starc I know you can simply set to be
Q times the sum of Peter Stark a try
okay now it supported kind of you don't
have to do that in practice writers or
because you wouldn't know be the star
obviously it's just a construction and
if you do that kind of and multiply it
out then you see due to these random
signs in expectation would you keep a
few if you multiply sigh h1 with psych a
in expectation it's 0 of course unless k
is equal to h1 so you only keep this one
term in there and would you sum is the
sum of K want to P be the star K the Q
still then then the probability that H 1
is really equal to K and now I've made
this lightly simplifying assumption for
the talk that say you've got exactly q
nonzero entries in each row then the
probability that a specific variable
which is active is coming up as the
first nonzero one is exactly 1 over Q so
this Q times probability h 1 is equal to
K actually is it's just one and it's
only one of the corresponding entry
index as one and so you see that this
term here is really equal to x ik and so
it means what you get an expected value
is just your X beta star okay so it
means if just dude one's kind of your
approximation is going to be unbiased
and so you just have to deal in a sense
if you want to get an approximation bond
you just have to deal with the with the
Barons which is induced kind of by the
random implementations and random songs
and you can get a better bounce if you
wait things a bit kind of so you
wouldn't want to put the full weight for
you for example on a variable which
comes up really late in the permutation
because the probability that that is
going to be chosen ass
the min has entry is really small so you
want to put most of the weight into the
front and actually you can choose the
way it's in an optimal way and if you do
that then you see again the the expected
value is okay and the band you get for
the approximation error is of the form
to 2k then the l2 norm squared of beta
star divided by L where L is again the
number of times can you do this whole
operation so the success is going to be
tied to the l2 norm of beer style which
is again it's very similar result I
mention that you would get for for
random projections for example saying
that if you are signals associated with
a direction kind of which has a high
variance it's much easier to deal with
that then if its associated kind of with
low variance component and so we wanted
to look a bit at the statistical
properties as well on for example look
at the mean squared error and so you
have to trade off a bit how large you
choose L so clearly the larger you 20
this small the approximation error is
going to be but the estimation error is
going to go up and you have to trade
these two off in an optimal way and if
you do that kind of you get a result
that the mean square error is going to
go down as low rate of sqrt 2 K over 2 q
/ n where Q's again the number of
nonzero entries you have in each row
times the l2 norm of B star and here
you've got an entry which is one if you
pick L in an optimal way and if you
don't pick it in an optimal way then you
pay a price for that because if you make
it too low the approximation error is
going to go up if you make it to launch
estimation error is going to go on and
have to say that that is a result
without any assumption on the underlying
design X and this is kind of awesome why
you get a kind of a slow rate which
would also get poison for LSU type
estimation if you don't make any ism
robotics and so in general you would be
consistent if PR n is going to 0 but you
can be doing much better again if the
signals associated you come with a
direction which has a high high burns
and X ok 44 rich progression wicked
really similar results are the the
changes in a sense that for least
squares estimation on as kind of you
have to be really careful how largely to
sell with rich progression counter you
can make L as large you want but then
you have to be careful obviously about
the tuning parameter but if you do that
right the result is exactly the same and
logistic regression also comes out to be
pretty much the same so this is all
assuming a linear model kind of floor
the underlying X and what I mentioned in
the beginning is sip is bits arm can you
can you do something bad interactions
and clearly it's challenging for example
if P is already a million kind of them
to encode on all interactions kind of
you would need an enormous data matrix
ax so we found surprising is really that
minimize hashing is dealing with some
form of interaction fitting
automatically you don't have to do
anything you can do exactly the same
procedure as before and you can fit
interactions with that and I say it's
doing it almost for free because the
price you pay is that you have to make
URL larger so you have to have a larger
set of projections so the key thing is
that obviously it's nonlinear operation
going on so if you think about a single
min wise hash operation what it might
look like is essentially you you get
almost like a random tree type operation
where in the first node you ask is the
bear
which are picked first in the random
permutation is that non zero and if it's
nonzero then i would i would give as
output the value of that random variable
if it is zero i asked kind of the next
variable in the randomly chosen
permutation of 20 and i continued until
a fun kind of nonzero entry and I return
the value of that variable x the
randomly chosen site so it's like a
random tree and and this also makes it
may be intuitively clear what you can
fit actually interaction because in this
case for example you can only get the
value minus x2 if x2 is non zero and the
first variable is exactly equal to 0 so
if you do that you can write down an
interaction model where you have your
signals essentially a linear term again
this is exactly the same as in the first
part and then you add interactions which
is now written down in this way if you
think about X's a binary matrix then
this model is encompassing actually all
pairwise interactions kind of you can
think of and you get a matrix now a
theta star too and if you define kind of
a known for this interaction model in
this way then the result you get is
exactly the same if you replace the two
norm of Peter Starwood with this L big
theta star so for example if you have no
interactions then of course kind of your
exactly back to the old result but the
interesting thing is in a sense that
suppose you you have response
interaction model so you just have a few
nonzero elements in there then this term
is going to contribute a queue and you
get a queue here and so if you look at
how many how many
protection scam you have to make so how
large you have to choose L then you have
to choose a lonely as larger than Q
squared P squared so which is obviously
a big saving in the medical tell example
Q's maybe a hundred or a thousand tennis
or so you would have to do a million
which is a lot better than 10 to the
power 12 yeah okay this is just kind of
then I mean the the approximation LLC
and then if you do come up with the
statistical part again obviously can you
get exactly the same results for the
linear part just that the two norm of
beer stars again replaced by this L of
theta star so it's kind of surprising in
a sense because you can't fit
interactions even though you just fit a
linear model on on on asthma I mean when
a sense it's not it's a problem with
when the beginning we were surprised
about it and you don't have to create
those interactions explicitly or code
them up which is perhaps more or less
automatically and the complexity saving
factors is usually q / p squared over
the brute force approach where brute
force would mean can you have to call
all interact us up and you don't even
have a budget for that but then you have
to compute your estimator kind of on
this fall interaction design as well and
there's a set kind of the price you have
to pay so that you have to make a lot a
lot larger and potentially then if you
just fit a linear model in your access
their importance is also something may
be of interest which hasn't been
discussed a lot so so far it's only been
about prediction buddy sometimes it's
still interesting how you want to know
which variables were really important or
you go in and say well so what happens
if i take this this bearable are kind of
do my predictions change
one or not and in the general case you
can ask for example what happens if i
set the cave barrel equal to zero what
how am i predict is going to change and
of course if you have a linear model
then you if you take the cave very large
you just have your contribution from xk
be the stock aware xk is your cave
variable and you can easily do this yeah
you just have to store three matrices
instead of one so the S matrix is
exactly the same as before and now you
have to construct the second one st odor
and still is constructed in a way such
that in the min wise hashing operational
don't look for the first nonzero entry
but you look for the second nonzero
entry and you always write down the
second nonzero entry and you have to
keep that matrix H as well in memory and
then you can say well f hat minus k is
exactly like that the reasoning being
that you look essentially for operations
kind of where the variable K came up
with the first nonzero entry and then
you think well if it had been zero
actually I would have picked the second
nonzero entry so if i multiplied in this
way i just replaced for those times
where the variable really came up with
the first nonzero entry i replace that
effectively with a zero entry and return
the value I would have gotten if it had
been zero so it's it it's very easy why
I kind of to to compute some kind of a
parable important scorers want to buy
not much more computational effort and a
really important point now a we have a
lot of numerical results but don't want
to bore you with that too much just
summarizing kind of the main points one
really important thing is in practice
that you can aggregate that so you can
do it you can do that procedure once and
then you can do it again and again and
you can just averaged out over the
results and it helps a lot because the
estimation error might stay the same but
your approximation error is going down
because you average out kind of the
randomness in the procedure which is
still there kind of if you just do it
once and it's it's unnecessary to have
them throw in there well kind of trivial
points the predictive accuracy can
decrease if you make l2 large obviously
because then you start to fill a lot of
noise and I would sum up the performance
pretty much that the absence of
interactions it's pretty similar to a
rich regression on the full dataset or a
random projection type operation and
actually I think there are reasons to
suspect it might be very similar indeed
from a theory important fusible the
interesting thing is if you add in
interactions it starts to fit them
automatically and it's it's not as good
then I mean if you have a really high
signal-to-noise ratio random forest is
always going to going to beat that but
it goes half of the way say but the
advantage is for example if your signal
noise ratio is really weak then random
forest is going to suffer a lot and and
this is not gonna suffer as much so it's
like a compromise between a richer
progression time estimation and a tree
ensemble type operation okay this is
just an example for a dataset can we
want to predict volatility based on on
text data so it's text regression
problem and you've got about four
million predictor variables which are
coding for words and by grams and you
can check kind of how good is your
forecast as a function of L as a
function of how many projections can you
make and here is compared kind of with
the zero added noise and then with added
noise as well and what you see here is
the correlation between your forecast
and
the actual values as a function of L so
Alice on that axis and it's going up
from 0 to 500 and grad is kind of what
we get come up with this win wise
hashing scheme and you see the
correlation is increasing then it's
flattering a bit and blues random
projections so it's working pretty much
the same it's a tiny bit worser than
their own projections and to test what
would happen if the truth have been just
a linear model kind of we just took the
same data matrix X and simulated and
underlying underlying linear model and
then you get a result which looks pretty
much the same so again kind of the
conclusion is well if it's if the line'
mall then actually it's doing very much
the same as a friend and projectors and
now if you include interactions for
example in the original arms then you do
see that you can fit in part of them so
the red ones now a lot better than the
blue random projection part as you would
expect because the letter obviously has
no chance can offer of a fitting those
interactions the second last example is
also just a stay a benchmark data set
can where you want to detect malicious
urls based on some information and the
dimensionality here is you've good 3
million pieces of information the
sparsity is again that just a few
thousand of them kind of might be active
n is 2 million and now we want you to
compare a kind of and not too too random
protectors comment but 22 what happens
if you use for example a rich estimator
or LSU estimator on the full data set
and we can only do that if we chopped on
the two million into smaller blocks
because otherwise kind of account can't
do two million by three million on a
laptop and if we did that kind of for
ten days when you see on the left is the
performance of the minimize hashing
scheme the dots
respond to these blocks so which
corresponds to days again kind of when
you want to make a forecast and the
performance is measured as Miss
classification error as a function of L
so you see if l is about four thousand
more or less converges and this is
compared to the LA Zoo on the raw data
and you get pretty much kind of the same
result so the nice thing is not again
kind of far you project down three
million to just a thousand dimensional
space and the result you get in terms of
predictive accuracy it's pretty much the
same in the middle is the result kind of
a few echo gave the left results 20
times so you do the procedure once and
again again and again and Everidge the
results and the end was that's going to
be very much the same but you need a
much smaller value film and sometimes
sometimes you can see kind of that
actually you can get an overall better
performance in this way and compared to
the rich data to a rich regression on
the original data it is actually doing a
lot better here but on the whole I would
say if you could do a rich estimator and
the model is approximately linear you
will get very similar results in if l is
not enough ok so the conclusions are
just that essentially I think what's an
interesting scheme because you can fit a
linear mall if you want to in a fast way
if there are strong interactions yeah
you're going to see them without having
to do anything explicitly about them it
just happens more or less automatically
thank
yeah you mean in terms of food he's
asking how it compares to a canada
project which so you mean in terms of
empirical performance or a theoretical
empirically I haven't tried it would be
interesting I was to see you well you
tell me I mean if anybody knows the
answer I'd be happy to do this was just
for the construction of the proof time
so you don't need to know them in
practice this was just the way I kind of
to construct your hypothetical be star
but in practice you don't need to know
them it was just why kind of to get a
good bond